MALE SPEAKER: Hello and welcome
to GDL-IL, GDL Israel.
Today we are very lucky to have
with us Shai, who is an
Angular expert.
And Shai will basically talk
with us about his personal
experience with Angular, and
what are a few of the cool
things that you could
do with it if you
are a front-end developer.
We'll dive in to a few of the
strengths, and hopefully
weaknesses, of Angular.
And we'll see why it's so
exciting to work with, and how
you could improve your best
practices and work with
dependency injections, with
test-driven development, and
other good old buzzwords that
actually work with Angular,
and getting out there and
gaining more and more momentum
in the community of front-end
developers.
So without further ado, maybe
I'll get Shai to explain us
first about himself and a short
bio of his experience.
And then we'll dive into a
few slides about Angular.
Sounds good?
SHAI REZNIK: OK, so
hey, everyone.
I'm Shai.
I'm a front-end developer a
few years now, and a lean
startupist.
I've been managing two groups,
one called JavaScript Israel
that gathers front-end
developers around JavaScript.
And it's a meet-up group.
And we do free event
to share knowledge.
And another group that's called
Talking Lean, where we
talk with entrepreneurs about
their lean startup
experiences.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll have
footnotes after the show with
all the links.
So don't bother to write
anything down.
SHAI REZNIK: And yeah, I've been
working with Angular over
one year now.
And I transitioned from other
frameworks, like Ember and
JavaScriptMVC, and
played around a
little bit with Backbone.
And I came from Flex, the Adobe
proprietary technology.
So it was a hard transition back
to JavaScript, because I
started with JavaScript before
the jQuery date.
And then I found Angular.
MALE SPEAKER: Luckily for you.
SHAI REZNIK: Yeah.
And after a lot of frustration,
and a lot of
playing around with different
feature of every framework,
Angular just hit home for me.
And I never looked back since.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Maybe we'll just jump for the
few slides that you prepared.
And we'll take it from there.
So feel free.
Now they are seeing the
screen, I could
make it even larger.
SHAI REZNIK: So these slides are
based on an introduction
to Angular meet-up we had.
It took about two
hours to give an
introduction of Angular.
You can find it.
If you search for Angular Hebrew
on YouTube, you will
find this lecture.
And this is just a brief
overview of the framework.
So a few facts.
It's created by Misko Hevery,
one of your guys, in 2009.
And after that, joined by other
developers from Google.
And they formulated it
into a 1.0 version.
It's unique features are
directives and dependency
injection, which I explain
furthermore.
It's powered by Google,
so it's a good thing.
And I don't think it's GitHub
updated data now, because it
was two months ago.
But I think it's way
past Ember by now.
It has a production stable
version, a lot of community
around it, good community that
contributes every day.
So it's a good sign that it's
healthy and keeps growing.
It's used by a few
large companies--
I personally consult to a very,
very large company now
that migrates to JavaScript
from an older technology.
And we use Angular to do it.
And they have great videos,
not so great
documentation now.
But they're great videos of
Misko and his friends about
the subject.
So a high level overview of the
architecture of Angular is
that you have the front--
I like to think of it
like the human body.
So you have the views which are
your sensors and voice,
and how you look and such.
And the views contain a unique
feature of Angular that's
called directives.
It also contains filters,
which can filter data.
And they combine inside the
template, which is basically a
plain old HTML.
Each part of that template of
the HTML you can wrap it
around with the controller,
which basically means that it
is a mini-brain of that
particular element, which give
it a link to the big application
which lies in your
services layer, which is
the big [? overmind ?]
brain that's knows all, and
knows how to connect to your
server and such.
And that way you have a clean,
nice architecture that you can
plug stuff out and
put stuff in.
And all you have to worry about
is your mini-controller,
mini-brain.
And it's supposed to be very,
very, very light.
So a word about templates--
so like I said, it's plain old
HTML, no special template
language other than the
directive, which is a big, big
part of Angular.
And their job is to
be declarative.
You declare what you
need on your HTML.
And then the Angular
just knows how
to tie things together.
In your controller, no
imperative logic is allowed.
And it's very good for content
security policy if you build
Chrome extension and you have
this limitation with
handlebars that I got
to using Ember.
In Angular, you don't have
this limitation.
MALE SPEAKER: One thing that I
might add is for developers
that are following and wish to
see how it will be to develop
to the web in the near future,
actually Angular give us today
the ability to do so with
declaratives, because
declaratives are quite similar
to what we are going to have
in the near future as
web components.
And it's a very, very cool way
to have encapsulation, which
we're lacking in the web.
I mean, we had it with iFrame.
But it's not on the web, and
it's quite cumbersome.
But here we have a really nice,
thin layer that enables
us to have dynamic HTML.
So it's more suited
to web apps.
SHAI REZNIK: I heard Misko
talked [INAUDIBLE]
a compliment that someone said
that the HTML6 is probably
called AngularJS.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's a good one.
SHAI REZNIK: Like [INAUDIBLE]
said, it's in the HTML.
It gives you a way to have a
domain-specific language, to
call things not by
divs and such.
But you can call it like you
want in your business, like
thumbnails or a model window,
and stuff like that.
You have components.
And you have containers that
you can contain other
directive or HTML inside them.
It's really, really good for
a don't-repeat-yourself
principle, a reuseability.
And it's similar to MXML,
if someone here
still works with Flex.
So the way they communicate
is via the scope.
So a scope is a really, really
interesting animal that
Angular brought to the table,
because it's unique because it
allows a clear separation
between the
view and the logic.
And the logic lies inside
the controller.
And the view and the
declarations lie inside of the
HTML and such on the template.
And they communicate
using a special
object called the scope.
And everything you want to be
rendered on your view you
attach to the scope.
And you put an expression in
your template that knows how
to watch the scope and
renders accordingly.
And every logic that you want
to enable on your view, you
just set a method.
But it's not really a method,
more like an event.
Because if you misspell the
name, you don't get an error.
And it knows to correlate
to the method on that
controller's scope.
So it's an object that lies
inside the controller which
Angular knows to set the
communication with the view
automatically.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess basically
the magic of the
two-way data binding
is happening here.
So that's exactly the
explanation that you give.
And one of the nice ways that
you can see it-- and we'll
have an example later on--
is that this "magic," quote,
unquote, is done for you.
So when we're saying something
like two-way data binding, the
beauty here is that, one, if the
user is changing the data
in the view, the controller
through the scope object will
be updated automatically for
you, and vice versa.
So everything that you will want
to drive from the service
side to the client will
be done in this way.
And we'll show you an
example of that.
SHAI REZNIK: It saves you a lot,
a lot of boilerplate code
that you used to do in jQuery,
playing with jQuery, when you
attach callbacks and write the
specific DOM manipulation to
do such and such when an
event occurs and such.
And it reduces all
this boilerplate.
So controllers are the
mini-brains, like I said.
It's more like a view model
not a [INAUDIBLE] or
presentation model, if you're
familiar with the old school
MVC definition.
You have a lot, a lot of MVC
definition nowadays.
So it can get quite confusing.
So it holds the special
scope object.
And responsible for the view
data presentation state and
reaction behavior.
So it's also responsible for
setting initial values, like
if you want default values to
be displayed on the start.
And it's the glue between the
view and the services.
So it's like a mediator between
the truth that we'll
talk about in the service
layer and your template.
So it's like you can filter
stuff out, depending on the
specific control.
So data binding we already
discussed.
It's really, really helpful, and
saves you a lot, a lot, a
lot of boilerplate code.
The service layer, this is one
of the things that I really,
really, really enjoyed when I
first learned about Angular.
And I didn't really see it
as a standard in other
frameworks.
So when I practiced Ember or
JavaScriptMVC, I needed a
place to hold stuff that aren't
really models and such,
just different pieces of logic
that I need to encapsulate and
to abstract in ways different
and to reserve the singular
responsibility principle,
which if you know the
[INAUDIBLE]
talks about clean
code and such.
So Angular introduces
it right inside the
framework as services.
So services are pieces of single
tones that Angular
manages for you.
And it allows you to inject them
to every single component
that you need inside of Angular
in a really easy way.
You just declare it by name on
the function that calls your
controller or other
services and such.
And you just get the
single tone.
And it really, really, really
simplifies your architecture,
because you don't need to
maintain all the different
instances that lies around
your application.
And it's also very, very good
for testing, because as you
know, we should test our
application more.
And we should need
more unit test.
And we don't do it usually
because it's hard.
It's hard in JavaScript still,
because even with all the
frameworks, it's still not that
easy to set a proper unit
test up, especially if you
don't have that the thing
called dependency injection.
You need to instantiate it.
And you need to configurate.
And it makes life really,
really hard.
And you have deadlines.
So you need to follow
the deadlines.
And you just drop the test.
So it makes your testing life
really, really easier.
And it gives you the ability,
instead of inherit from other
classes, like a typical
prototype inheritance, you get
the ability to add
mixins of stuff.
If you need an ability to call
a server, you just inject the
HTTP service, or another custom
server that you created
with an abstract
layer above it.
You need a way to manipulate
some depth and some specific
business logic.
Just inject the specific
service and use it.
And you have this ability.
You don't need to inherit
from anyone.
And it's really, really helpful,
and also protects
[INAUDIBLE], because
you divide your
code into small modules.
So the modeling in Angular
is native JavaScript.
You don't have a special
model object--
just arrays and objects
and what you know.
You have specific services for
communication with Ajax, and
more optimized for REST.
And probably we'll see an
example later, which is called
the q, which basically is the
promise, HTTP, which wraps
around a native Ajax
of JavaScript.
And we have the resource, which
communicates with REST resources.
So Angular, in that sense, is
optimized for promises.
So also, promises is a concept
that really also makes your
asking life easier, because it
removes all the callback
pyramid nightmare.
And it allows you to
pass along objects
and work with objects.
But Angular still doesn't have
a proper solution for entity
management, or persistent
management.
Because if you have a difficult
service side model
or complicated--
sorry--
so you don't have a really
good way now to handle it
natively inside of Angular
to declare
dependencies between entities.
And you have a user which
[INAUDIBLE], and I don't know,
have comments, and
blah-blah-blah.
You don't have a really good
way to declare it and to
manage it properly.
So you have third party
libraries like [? with JS, ?]
which as for now, I think,
it's probably the most
comprehensive or the biggest
solution now.
But still, I find it hard to
work if you don't have .net--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
SHAI REZNIK: No.
Server, backend.
And I still would love to see
more support for Java and
other backends for better
integration.
So dependency injection,
I already discussed.
It works really, really good.
You have a lot of helper
methods to declare your
injectables.
And Angular knows how to create
a provider for them.
And the other topics we
already discussed.
You have also the concept of
filters, which basically, in
Angular, transforms input.
It also sorts.
It also filters stuff out.
It transforms your input into
something, like plain text
into uppercase and such.
And [INAUDIBLE]
that way that you can inject
inside of different templates,
which aren't really supposed
to be inside a specific
[INAUDIBLE].
A good example for that
is localization.
Localization, when you need to
render a text according to the
locale that the application
is using.
Filter is really, really,
really a good
solution for that.
It saves you a lot of code
and ins and outs, and
blah-blah-blah.
So this is about filters,
testing.
I already mentioned about Misko
who came from a testing
background.
He has a lot of lectures
about the subject.
He wrote it with testing
in mind.
And they wrote an extension
above Jasmine, but with
important Angular helpers that
gives you the ability to
simulate the dependency
injection, and give you
injection on the fly in your
test, if you need it.
And you don't have to
instantiate anything and such.
Also, I need to update
it, because it's
not Testacular anymore.
It's Karma.
They finally changed
their name.
And if somebody's interested
in the subject, you have a
good resource and a very
wonderful site that's called
Yearofmoo that is known for
its very, very long and
thorough posts on different
subjects,
and especially Angular.
So testing, really easier than
any other framework--
MALE SPEAKER: I think it's
one of maybe the
strengths of Angular.
And as we all know, usually
projects start low when timing
the scope, but quite quickly
becoming larger and larger.
And if you want to be on top of
things and make sure that
you are able to move with them
quickly, testing is one the
must-have things.
That's result date.
SHAI REZNIK: Really, really
brief, I won't get
into it very deep.
It's just my experience.
It's not like a fact or
something like that.
Why I found Angular so good.
And you have an asterisk on the
side of Backbone because I
didn't really use Backbone
that much.
I only did a small POC just
to find out how it works.
And so in case of the most
important features that I
looked for in terms of stability
and reliability,
clear structure, which Angular
was the only one that provided
me the services, as I mentioned
before, and the clear--
it made be ask less questions
about which stuff goes where.
Testing is also--
I don't know how it
is with Backbone.
I believe it's good.
But with Ember, I had a lot
of headaches with it.
Lazy people oriented, which is
my personal favorite, because
I want to be as lazy as
possible, Angular really,
really gives me that
with dependency
injection and bindings.
Which also Ember is more
towards this with their
bindings and conventions
over configurations.
A strong community, really,
really, really important.
JavaScriptMVC, if anyone hear
this or listen to this and
considers JavaScriptMVC,
don't.
Learning curve.
In terms of learning
curve, Backbone is
really, really small.
So it was really, really
simple to understand.
But it's really small.
You don't get a lot of the
stuff that you get with
Angular and Ember.
You need to plug in stuff from
third party libraries.
And you have a million
you have to
choose from every where.
So Angular gives you that
really, really ease.
But the learning curve
of Angular and Ember
is still not optimal.
Because Angular, if you want
to do basic stuff, simple
stuff, render something on the
screen and have two-way
binding, all the examples on
the main site of their
website, it's really,
really easy.
But when you start and want
to create more complicated
directives or want to handle
other stuff, you need to
really understand what is the
life cycle and how the
workflow works, and need to
grasp really, really key stuff
that the documentation
isn't really good at.
And in those terms, I
think it's worth it.
It's worth the right, if
you consider Angular.
But you need to give it its
time, really give it
time to sink in.
And once you get it, you run.
You run forward.
And you just have all the
tools that the strong
framework can give you.
So in terms of the other stuff,
expandability and play
well with others, I found
Angular really good.
Size also is not that
meaningful.
And performance, although it's
debatable in comparison with
Ember performance, they're
really improving stuff with
every version.
So that's it, a brief
overview.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
And maybe we could definitely
get the screenshot out.
Do we want to share--
let's see here.
We have two nice, quick examples
that we could run on
the code and just show stuff.
SHAI REZNIK: You want
to share it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Let's share this screen again.
And it's this one.
Let me try and make
it even bigger.
So please, feel free.
SHAI REZNIK: So we can see a
really, really basic example
of the resource service
as I mentioned before.
So its job is basically to wrap
around a resource, a REST
URI, and to give you a simple
way to handle it
object-orientedly.
So you define your URI.
And you get your different
method.
You get four or five
methods for free.
You get Query and Post
and Sort and
Create and Get and such.
You can read more.
We can open also the
documentation.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we'll have
the link in the footnotes.
SHAI REZNIK: And then
you get an object.
Once you get that object,
you can perform
different actions on it.
And you get a lot of work done
by Angular in the background
that goes to the server, fetch
the JSON, the response.
MALE SPEAKER: Building the
object in the scope.
SHAI REZNIK: Yeah.
Building the object
in the scope.
And then it creates--
in every object that you get,
you get an instance of that
research that you defined.
And you have the ability to
perform actions like update
the JavaScript object.
And you have a special
method that's called
[? dollar-save. ?]
And then you save.
And it's also Angular from
behind the scenes, goes to the
server, and updates what needs
to be updated and such.
So this is just really,
really quick.
It shows you a really, really
simple fiddle that shows you
how you can search Twitter by
their public API using JSONP
for the response.
And you get the Twitter results
as a promise, like I
mentioned before.
And when you get it as a
promise, Angular knows how to
render this promise
automatically, again.
MALE SPEAKER: And it will show
the template that will take it
and show you [INAUDIBLE].
That's actually pretty cool.
Maybe you take it from the top,
just to explain to the
ones that never saw
an Angular app.
The first time, we're just
declaring [INAUDIBLE].
SHAI REZNIK: So you need to
pick your scope when you
define an application.
And usually it's on the HTML.
But you can define it on
any element you want.
And that element and boundwards
will be inside the
Angular ward.
So you give your application a
name, in this case Twitter.
And you have the concept
of controllers,
like I mentioned before.
So you give your
control a name.
And then here, they just
declare it as a global
function, which Angular
knows how to pick up.
But usually [INAUDIBLE]
calling your application
[INAUDIBLE]
Angular application.
And [INAUDIBLE]
once you declare it, you
have a reference.
And you have helper methods.
[INAUDIBLE]
the controller method.
And it's the same [INAUDIBLE]
due to the [INAUDIBLE]
controller.
[INAUDIBLE]
and not as a global function,
because this is polluting the
global scope.
MALE SPEAKER: But usually we'll
try to maybe encapsulate
it in some global environment
that will include everything
that we do in the app
itself, right?
SHAI REZNIK: Yeah, you have the
option of also declaring
it as a global scope variable.
MALE SPEAKER: For
the app itself.
SHAI REZNIK: For the app itself,
and then you can
attach stuff to it.
I personally prefer the
whole longer version.
Also, they pollute the global
scope as less as possible.
So here, once you declare
the [INAUDIBLE]
controller, you get a wrapping
around your div here by that
controller.
And each variable or reference
that you defined under this
div, under this HTML elemental
or DOM element, get
automatically watch expression
that watches this scope object
of your controller.
And here is the example that
once you get the Twitter
results, you get it inside of
Twitter result and inside of
result property.
And once you get the result
property, which basically is
an array, you get free Angular
directive, called Entry
Repeat, which lets you declare
just a DOM element that you
want to be repeated.
And you get an instant scope.
So inside of that element, you
get a reference to the
specific instance of
the iteration.
And that way, in each iteration,
it will render the
different texts that came
back from Twitter,
here in this example.
So you get iteration over the
Twitter results, which once
you called Twitter results, it
came back with an object, with
a result property, which
is an array.
And then it's really, really
as simple as that, just
declaring a watch expression
that watches your specific
instance of the--
MALE SPEAKER: It's tracing
the array, right?
SHAI REZNIK: What?
MALE SPEAKER: So basically we
got here a free iterator that
will go over the array and will
render each sale as a
tweet.text.
And we could put tweet dot time
and date, whatever, all
the other parameters that
we have here for free.
So that's basically what Entry
Repeat give us, right?
SHAI REZNIK: Yeah.
It's specific for each instance,
and just common
behavior that you want
to render arrays in.
So you get everything.
It's really look how
much lines of code.
It's really, really,
really simple.
And you just can search for--
I don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Angular.
SHAI REZNIK: Angular.
And once it come back, it
gives you the results.
Really, really, really
simple, really easy.
You get it with your
ngResource.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So I think in matters of time,
we covered most of the things
that we wanted.
If there are any questions
now on the chat or
just live, feel free.
And if not, we'll wrap it up.
And hopefully you'll be able to
join us in the future to do
a followup, and dive deep
to other subjects
that we cover briefly.
SHAI REZNIK: Of course.
I'll be happy to.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
So do we have any questions?
If you wish, this is the
time to ask them.
Cool.
So thank you very much
for being with us.
And we'll see you next
week on Wednesday,
2:00 PM Israel time.
Thank you very much, Shai.
SHAI REZNIK: OK, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Bye-bye.